[Music]
you seem like a grinder when you were
building these businesses
were you just like uh doing 80 hour 100
work weeks and what about now because
you're like
yolked you're a huge you look like a
bodybuilder so so like how did you
balance like uh being fit and getting
married and you but
i don't know you well but you seem like
you'd be grinding hard so my wife works
in the business with me so we are true
50 50 partners like
it's very rare i like i recognize how
rare it is she actually is 100 matched
with me
and like should just as much be on this
call because she runs the other half
like she
from a work standpoint she has more
output than i did um she is the operator
so she builds the infrastructure she
does the recruiting she sets the they
are the hr stuff she does the culture
she like she does i mean she runs
everything um i just you know
occasionally come up with a good idea
and try and stick with it long enough um
to see it come true but in terms of
grinding
we this is what we like i love business
like i love this and there's nothing
that really stimulates me like this and
so i do as much of it as i can and if we
want to go to dinner we'll go to dinner
you know but like worse we're i was just
saying we're single so we don't have
kids and so we work from like
five-ish to
four ish you know
um
and then
you know usually in the middle of the
day we'll probably go to the gym for an
hour or two and then come back and keep
working and go out to dinner at night
and that's that's kind of our lives
you seem pretty um this isn't i would
say i'm a little bit i'm definitely this
sean has a little bit of it too like
manic's not the right word but like
neurotic maybe is a better word um where
it's like uh
you're there's something that's deep
rooted inside of you that's kind of
it's not like you want to do something
necessarily it feels like you're it's
more compulsive
um or obsessed you're obsessed about
stuff which i am as well
um where if that's true what's that
rooted in what are you trying to get
done
so i think originally the drive was from
just crippling insecurity and needing
approval right
um and then i think from like a
behavioral conditioning standpoint i
got immediate feedback that was positive
and then i was conditioned to continue
those actions now
uh
i continue to do them without the
original catalyst that got them going to
begin with so i don't i don't think i
suffer you know from the insecurities as
much as i used to i'd say i'm probably
30 better than i was at the beginning
and it might just be because i have this
massive big pile of money that i can use
as an emotional crutch to why i'm not a
piece of
um
that would help i'm just being like i
mean if it were all disappeared i'd find
out how much actual growth i had or if i
just compensated by circumstance and you
know compensate for the division yeah i
don't know you can send it to me and
we'll we'll find out we'll see
let's run the experiment i like
so there's the compulsion and like this
last year i pretty much took off like i
did not work that much um
and so i saw the difference and like i
have i have come to accept that i love
working and i don't need to judge myself
for that or
or take in other people's judgment on
how much i should quote do
like this is my life and this is what i
like doing
and their
ideals that they've arbitrarily made up
as what they define as balance are
irrelevant to me
you said you took last year off what'd
you do
what'd you get up to we went out to
dinner every single night to a five-star
restaurant for seven straight months we
went to i mean we we moved to vegas
temporarily um we traveled a lot uh went
to cabo went to scottsdale went to
sedona went to flagstaff
traveled all over um
went out
did stuff
um
felt honestly pretty empty like you can
only eat so many times like there's just
not a lot to do um it feels good having
that rest though i mean when i sold my
company which was a year ago last week
the first six six months i was like i
need to decompress it felt good to have
it and then and then i was like and i'm
in that phase now where i'm like all
right now i'm ready for war again you
you can't like i i like you can't be in
the trenches i think like or rather you
need breaks from from being in the from
being at war i think and maybe even
phrasing it i'm just throwing this out
there like phrasing it is instead of a
like a break is a shift in how you're
thinking because like it's really like
it's going from dirt to clouds but i
still think it's high leverage
activity you know what i mean or like
output it's just a different type of
output
you said something on one of your videos
that um you're one of the only other
people that i have heard say this phrase
i use it a lot which is
yeah i had a season like or this season
i'm doing this or i had a season where i
was really just focusing on x
and that's been like a game changer for
me my personal trainer and kind of coach
he's like my mindset coach plus trainer
he does this all the time but he's like
he's like i'm in a season right now
where i'm
i'm just uh he'll be like you know i'm
practicing not waiting and he's like hey
he comes up with these little themes or
he'll be like right now i'm in a season
where i'm going to eat whatever i want
and it's kind of like in the
entrepreneurial world it's like time
boxing's like all right i'm going to
give myself two hours to get this
done or i'm going to launch in the next
two weeks no matter what right like we
i've used time boxing for productivity
and now this season's thing it makes
every like decision you're making less
heavy of a commit because you're like
it's okay yeah because there's yeah
there's beginnings and ends and this
season is gonna feel a little different
just like winter feels different than
summer that's how i use it do you do you
use it like that i just noticed you said
that phrase
yeah and maybe it's a fitness thing i
have no idea um i i've yeah i i have no
ownership right like a season
yeah i mean i i think about it in terms
of entrepreneurial seasons
um and i at least for me might have been
like five year chunks
and so this is gonna be my fourth season
um and they've roughly been about the
same length so i think that it probably
takes me like
three ish years to like
really see something through and then
two years to figure out how i'm going to
transition from that thing or realize or
mod you know whatever um that's what i
it's kind of like a pe cycle almost
[Music]